ربما يبدو لنا هذا الحوار عليا لكنه يحمل
في جواب الرئيس الامريكي جوبيدا تفسيرا
يساعده على البراءه من سوء استعمال
الوثائق السريه
الوثائق لم تكن في الشارع
يخضع تصنيف المعلومات والوثائق في الحكومه
الامريكيه لسلمى متصاعد وهو كونفدنشل او
خاص ثم سكرت وسري والتصنيف الاخير
جدا وهذا التصنيف يرتبط ليس في المضمون
بقدر ما يرتبط بكثره الضرر الذي يتسبب به
المضمون لون نشر
للملانجلش انه امر خطير لانه يمكن
متعاونين من مواطنين دول اخرى ويتعرضون
للموت او للعقاب ما حصل مع الرئيس الحالي
جوبيدا وسلفه دونالد ترامب هو احتفاظهم
بوثائق مصنفه بدل من ان تكون هذه الوثائق
بحوزه البيكالات المختصه او المحفوظات
الوطنيه
جدا او انها مواد حساسه يمنع الاطلاع
عليها الا من قبل اشخاص معنيين مباشره
بمضمونها ولديهم اذن خاص وفي مكان وربما
يكون الحال هو ذاته مع
بيضربي
يصل الى مستوى التصنيف للماده واجب ان
تحتاج لمعرفه المضمون
يرى الرئيس الامريكي الحليب انه يواجه
فضيحه اتهم بها خصبه السياسي ليشكك في
تصرفاته والبيت الابيض يعاني الان من
ملاحقات الصحفيين والامريكيين له في هذه
القضيه
مختلفه لما كان الامر مهما لكنه كان ينتقد
الرئيس ترامب لسوره التصرفاته بالوثائق
المطلقه
مع الاهتمام بقضيه ترامب معتبرا ان تصرفات
ترامب غير مسؤوله
الرئيس هو ان الوثائق التي كانت بحوزته
كانت في مكان مقفل ولم يطلع عليها احد ولو
ثبت عكس ذلك فانه في ورطه كبيره في الغنم
العربيه